can I say this all right it's I
think because of the G the the newer
generation is very
sensitive they are yeah I agree as a as
a generation they're a little bit more
sensitive as comedy fans especially as
comedy fans you can even call but the
comics are a little sensitive yeah like
when you see younger Comics around you
literally have to watch yeah like don't
say this don't say this don't say I've
said him trust me it doesn't go well
yeah right and so I think that like like
but what I think is especially for
Comics like this in Texas this guy is a
warrior you know how hard comedy
is it's pretty tough right and you went
up every night every night you're a
strong guy you can take some criticism
please Bobby your lips dude I come here
you start complimenting the [__] out of
me and you don't like it n it's just
it's too much Bobby your eyebrows can
you say something about your eyebrows
too they're [__] perfect too like
thin they're not thin at all no the
thickness yours is thicker like this way
but in terms of like it's yeah yeah I'm
not saying thickness you know what I
mean I do all right yeah I
[Laughter]
haven't my sister does my eyebrows for
me but I haven't done them in like a
couple months really she does them what
do you mean like she'll like pluck them
with like little tweezers and stuff yeah
like shape them up cuz I grow a mean ass
unibrow I got an Alaskan B mommy oh you
do yeah wow dude some one day I'm going
just do it I'm going just grow it out
you know but your eyebrows I think
that's a good look yeah yeah try it
you're a hairy dude not too much in some
places some yeah right there yeah you
can grow beard too I wish it was better
it's an all right beard let me see the
size look this this side and then
there's this side yeah Puck your lips a
little bit oh hey do do beards do beards
get more like filled out as you get
older like when did you grow your you
need more like life experience for them
to really thicker yeah cuz he's GNA well
no like when did your mustache start to
grow in always you always had had it
when you were younger oh you going to
make fun of it go ahead no no no no no
go go get me that's a good mustache
that's a nice dark mustache D you know
what dude let me say something about
your energy right now right every since
since you've been here you've been my
homie dude you've been backing me up
dude yeah you're skinny huh yeah I'm
pretty I'm pretty skinny dude so what
I'm saying to you right now already off
the bat dude you and I dude in any kind
of World War III any apocalypse anything
we're on the same team dude okay we we
we'll Harbor together you'll be you know
make a fort you know what I mean how can
be there
Karina right maybe yeah yeah H Me Maybe
maybe look at it look at that thumbs up
I'm just jealous that's all I'm hating
cuz I'm jealous like this man can't give
me a direct answer my whole life but you
turn around he's like thumbs up for sure
Bobby
like yeah dude you I like you too man
you're a good guy yeah so so George have
you met George before though like
physically mm oh you should do his
podcast I'm down have you asked
nah why I don't know in terms of the
Hispanic Comics I'm going to just say
who's been who you like I'm going to
just name some Hispanic yeah you like
all of them Filipe Filipe sparza that's
so great why you make that
face you do like that no I love phip
he's done our I've known Filipe since he
was a kid dude really that's badass well
I've known him
since at least two 1999 2000 maybe that
that time damn yeah for a long time dude
I knew him Gabriel everybody back then
you know but it's like you're right do
you guys have similar energy I guess
yeah a little bit maybe what do you mean
maybe I don't know it's
like I'll tell you what it's um and I
don't want to get in trouble for this
but I want to say something okay I was
hanging out
with he's scared that I G to say
something crazy and just listen what's
up Ral nitrous that's right dog nitrous
infused cold brew coffee with Sicilian
lemons you can read too huh got god dude
you're you're a mind warper huh I'm
going to say this somebody said to me um
I go you know there's a lot of Asian
people doing it but I don't know how I
you know was able to put and they go
dude you're not Asian you're [__]
weird what who said that to you 100%
like it's not even just I've never met
they go I've never met a Korean like you
yeah but I've never met a human being
like you you're in your own kind of a
thing but I think because you're Asian
it adds it compounds it adds to the
insanity yeah you were always like the
Renegade like the rebellious Asian
guy
right and he's like that too there's a
weird like I can't put them in a box
almost yeah you know that wasn't made
for boxes me either
did those Corners out of
here yeah